So, this is build machines with the size and the power consumption of an
entire town, to study tiny subnuclear effects.
They built telescopes distributed over several continents orbiting
the earth and space, to look back or out into the universe. So isn't
our knowledge physics accurate enough already? And,
how many significant digits do we really need?
>> The purpose of building big accelerators, is not
to improve the number of significant figures. it is to discover new phenomena.
It is to discover, in discovering, for example.
That a nucleus is made of protons and neutrons. That was a discovery at one
time, all right? One wasn't, one wasn't improving the
accuracy of the old theory. One was discovering something genuinely new.
New phenomena that there were things called
protons and neutrons. When the atom was
discovered to be electrons going around in
orbit in quantum mechanical orbits, that was
not improving accuracy. It was discovering a whole new way to fear/g, to think
about the world. The big machines that
are being built, to understand, let us say,
elementary particles, are not being built to
imp, for the purpose of improving the
accuracy. let's say for chemistry or for whatever they're being built to try to
understand what, what the real phenomena at the at the
base of our basic understanding of the world. and of what makes up matter,
what makes up things, and
it, it's not that it's going to improve the accuracy. It's going to change
the whole picture of the way we think things work. The same is true with
the big telescopes. Now, sometimes it's important
to improve accuracy. We have various ideas, for example, about
something called dark energy. Dark energy is the energy that's out there
in space that is causing the universe
to accelerate and expand faster and faster. the
various ideas may be very different than each other, but they may give rise to
answers which are pretty similar. And in that case, we build the machines to be
more accurate to describe, to try to
discriminate between different possibilities. But the different possibilities
really describe very, very different kinds of understandings of the world. So,
sometimes yes, we just really do want to improve the number of significant
figures. Also, sometimes in proving the number of significant figures,
figures, you discover discrepancies. An example might be,
studying the properties, the detailed properties of electrons.
The properties of electrons, many of them are know to God knows how
many significant figures. eighth while they say,
that's a lot of significant figures. Supposing
we make a more accurate measurement and we discover that in the ninth
significant figure we don't agree experiment with
theory. That could really tell us something,
very deep about what the next step will be in understanding
elementary particles. So yeah, we do want to improve accuracy.
But mostly, we want to discover new phenomena, new, not just
new phenomena but new understandings of what the old phenomena are.